now that we know a little bit about a
heat of formation and enthalpy change
and what enthalpy is we can talk a
little bit about Hess's law
Hess's law and what this tells us is
that the energy change of a process is
independent of how we get from one state
to another and it's it's it and really
that's a byproduct of the fact that
energy is a state variable whether we're
talking about enthalpy or internal
energy their state variables and we've
talked multiple times that it's
independent of how many steps it takes
to get there or what path you happen to
take but how is that useful to us when
we're dealing with everyday reactions so
let's say let me just make up some
reaction where I have or I have a plus B
is yields oh I don't know let's just say
this yields C plus D and I wanted to
figure out what was the change in
enthalpy of this reaction or essentially
how much heat is absorbed or released by
this reaction I don't know what it is I
don't I haven't measured it and all I
have are the heats of formation so all I
know is how do you go so I know the heat
of formation of a so let me call that
the heat of formation and remember H
isn't for heat even though we kept
calling it heat of formation it's
actually the change in enthalpy and it's
the standard change in enthalpy but the
change in enthalpy we know is Heat so
it's heat change in enthalpy of
formation is same thing as heat of
formation this little knot sign tells
it's the standard heat of formation we
can look up that in a table and let's
say that that's some number and then we
have our heat of formation of B Delta
heat of formation let me call it of B
this is heat of formation of a and it's
a standard heat of formation and we can
look up on a table the heat of formation
of C heat of formation of C just change
in enthalpy and then the heat of
formation for D so all of these things
we can look up in the table right and I
will do that in a second now what Hess's
law tells us is that the change in
energy the change in an enthalpy is what
we're measuring here the change in
enthalpy here is independent of what
we're doing so instead of saying this
reaction we could say hey let's go from
this react
and go back let me do it in a different
color let's go back to our constituent
products so kind of the elemental form
of these so you know if this was like
carbon dioxide you'd be going back to
the carbon and the oxygen molecule so
you'd go back to the elemental form and
how much energy or what's the change in
enthalpy is you go back to the elemental
form the heat of formation is what you
get from the elemental form to a or the
elemental form to B so to get a and B
back to the elemental form it's going to
be the minus of those you're going to
take the reaction in the other direction
so it's going to be so that this change
is going to take minus Delta the heat of
I guess a forming a we give you the
minus or the heat it's the heat of
deconstructing a you can almost view it
and it would also be minus the same
thing for B for B and then this is just
the elemental form and now we can go
from the elemental form back to the
products because we have the same atoms
here they're just rearranging themselves
into two different sets of molecules so
now we can go back from the elemental
form and go up here and we know what
those are we know how much energy it
takes to go from the elemental form to C
and D that's their heats of formation so
Hess's law tells us that Delta H of this
reaction Delta H of this reaction the
change in enthalpy of this reaction is
essentially going to be the sum of what
it takes to decompose these guys which
is the minus heat of formations of these
guys plus what it takes to reform these
guys over here so we can just write it
as Delta H I'll just write it Delta H of
formation for C plus Delta H of
formation for D so the heat of formation
of these guys - these guys this is what
it took you to get to the elemental form
so minus Delta heat of formation of a
minus Delta heat of formation of B and
then you'll have the heat of the
reaction and if it's negative we would
have released energy and if this number
is positive then that means that there's
more energy here than on this side so we
would have to
orab energy for this reaction to happen
it would be endothermic so this is all
abstract and everything and I've talked
about told you about Hess's law let's
actually apply it to some problems so
let's say I have this reaction right
here where I start with ammonia and it's
ammonia gas and I'm going to react that
with molecular oxygen to yield some
nitrogen monoxide four moles of it and
some water so what's the heat of this
reaction right here so what we do is we
just look up the heats of formation of
each of these so let's just look them up
let's start with the ammonia what's the
heat of formation of ammonia and this is
it's always given in kilojoules per mole
so they'll say to form one mole of
ammonia so to form one mole of ammonia
let's look up here this is all cut and
pasted from Wikipedia and am I starting
in the gaseous or the aqueous state well
I I think I just see I'm starting the
gaseous data I've added that G there so
ammonia and the gaseous state has a heat
of formation of minus forty five point
nine / - so what is that going so minus
forty five point nine kilojoules per
Joule per mole
so minus forty five point nine that's
just for one mole of ammonia the heat of
formation it's in kilojoules I'll just
look them up look them all up right now
now what's the heat of formation of
oxygen and I'm not going to look it up
right now because oxygen is it is in its
elemental form so if you see something
in the form that it just always takes
before you know you do anything to it
its heat of formation is zero so if you
co2 its heat of formation is zero if you
see hydrogen if you ch2 its heat of
formation is here if you see carbon by
itself heat of formation is here carbon
in the solid state heat of formation is
zero at standard temperature and
pressure
now what about nitrogen monoxide let's
look that up nitrogen monoxide I have it
right here nitrogen monoxide heat of
formation it's positive ninety point two
nine ninety point two nine
ninety point two nine and finally what's
the heat of formation of water well let
me see
water water is water liquid water - two
eighty five point eight three - two
eighty five point eight three - two
eighty five point eight three now you
might be tempted to say okay Hess's law
says that if we want the Delta H for
this reaction we just take this Plus
this and subtract that and you would be
almost right but you would get the
problem wrong because these are the heat
of reaction of formation per mole but we
notice in this reaction we have four
moles of this plus five moles of this
reeled four moles of this plus six moles
of that so we have to multiply this
times the number of moles so here I have
to multiply this times four four here
and I have to multiply it times four
here and have to multiply times six here
I don't even worry about multiplying
zero times five because it's just going
to be zero so now we can apply Hess's
law to figure out the Delta H of this
reaction so the Delta H of this reaction
of this reaction is going to be equal to
four times the heat of formation of
nitrogen monoxide so four times ninety
point two nine plus six times the heat
of formation of water so plus I'll
switch colors
six times minus two eighty five point
eight three and just as a side note
given that the heat of formation of
nitrogen monoxide is positive that means
that you have to add heat to a system to
get this to a net to its elemental form
so it's it has more energy than its
elemental form so it won't just happen
by itself and water on the other hand it
releases energy when you form it from
its elemental form so it's in some ways
it's more stable but anyway let me so
these are the these are the heats of
formations of the products and then we
want to subtract out the heats of
formation of the of the reactants in our
reaction so here it's four times forty
five point nine I'm gonna make sure it's
a minus forty five
- 45.9 right that was ammonia had a -
45.9 heat of formation so what do we end
up with let me get the calculator out so
I have let me make sure let me put it
over here I have to be able to read it
well I'll just do it off the screen
because my screen is getting filled up
so I have a let me just do it here for
ya four times ninety point two nine plus
six times two eighty five point eight
three negative is equal to so so far
we're at minus thirteen fifty three and
does that run sound about right yeah
that looks about right and now we want
to subtract from that four times minus
forty five point nine so we want to
subtract so minus four times forty five
point nine negative is equal to minus
eleven seventy so our Delta H of this
reaction is equal to minus eleven
seventy kilojoules kilojoules for this
reaction and all we did is we took the
heat of formation of the products
multiply it times the number of moles
and subtract it out the heat of
formation of the actual reactants there
you go let's do one more of these let's
say I had some propane I had some
propane and I'm going to combust it I'm
going to oxidize the probe the propane
to yield some carbon dioxide and water
well it's the same drill what's the heat
of formation of propane look it up here
it is amazing how exhaustive these lists
really are propane is down here in its
liquid state heat of formation - 104.7
so let me write that down
- 104.7 heat of formation of what of
oxygen is elemental state that's how you
always find oxygen so it's just zero
heat of formation of carbon dioxide and
see carbon dioxide and as a gas - three
93.5
- three 93.5 and water we already
figured that out it's minus two eighty
five point eight three minus two eighty
five point eight three so how much heat
is form from we combust one mole of
propane right here so let's see we have
to take we have to figure out the heat
of the products the heat of formation of
the products so it's going to be three
times this cuz we form three moles of
this for every mole we released this
much energy and then plus four times
this and then subtract out one times
this so what do we get we get three
times three ninety three point five
that's a negative is equal to that plus
four times two eighty five point eight
three negative is equal to minus 2,300
kilojoules roughly and then we have to
subtract out one times this or we could
just add 104.7 so let me just do that
so plus 104.7 is equal to minus twenty
two hundred so here my change my heat of
this reaction is equal to minus twenty
219 kilojoules kilojoules as we go in
this direction so for every mole of
propane that I combust I will actually
produce this much energy on the other
side because this right here has it has
two thousand roughly 2200 less
kilojoules than this side right there so
I could actually rewrite this reaction
where I write all that and I could have
added let me actually let me do it I
could rewrite this reaction as c3h8
propane plus five oxygens yields three
carbon dioxides plus four waters plus
2219 kilojoules that's actually what's
released by this reaction it's
so thermic this side of the reaction has
less heat than this side and that didn't
just disappear it got released and this
is where it got released now sometimes
you'll see a question where they say hey
fair enough you figured out the heat of
this reaction how much heat is going to
be released if I were to hand you I
don't know let's say I were to hand you
33 grams 33 grams of propane well then
you just start thinking oh well how many
moles of propane this is because if I
combust one mole of propane I get this
much heat so how many moles of propane
is 33 grams well how much does one mole
weigh the one mole of carbon so one mole
of carbon weighs 12 grams one mole of
hydrogen weighs one gram so one mole of
propane is going to be three times 12 so
times three because we have three
carbons there and eight hydrogen's so
times eight so it's going to be equal to
36 plus eight so it's going to be 44 so
this is going to be 44 grams per mole
right this is let me write that down
44 grams per mole now if I give you 33
grams how many moles am I giving you
well 33 grams times I guess we could say
1 over 44 moles per gram for the whole
gram there and then the grams cancel I'm
giving you 33 over 40 fourths of a mole
or I'm giving you Oh point seven five
moles so if one mole produces this much
energy 3/4 of a mole is going to produce
3/4 of this so we just multiply that
times 0.75 so times 0.75 and you get 16
64 so times 0.75 is equal to 16 64 so if
I were to give you one mole of propane
and I were to combust it with enough
oxygen I'll produce 2200 kilojoules
that's released from the cyst
so this side of the system has less
energy left over but if I were to only
give you 33 grams which is 3/4 of a mole
then you're going to release 6 roughly
1600 kilojoules anyway hopefully you
found that helpful